I guess I ultimately think we need to
reach the point where not just a few of
our nation's leaders but but many many
many of them understand what you
understand after you've taught
successfully in a low-income community
which is a couple of things one it's
just you understand we can solve the
problem because once you realize that
then you realize we have to prioritize
the issue and and work relentlessly to
actually reach the goal of solving the
problem the other thing is I think you
come out of this experience of teaching
successfully rejecting any Silver Bullet
theory so you come in and you think its
funding or it's maybe technology or it's
it's a curricular approach or whatever
and many people in our country are still
searching for the silver bullet you come
out of this realizing okay it's it's no
one thing it is everything you know
there are no shortcuts to quote a crew
of our folks who've started these very
high-performing charter schools the Kipp
academies it's about it's about doing
everything well just as in the same way
that success in any other sector we
always know in business and government
whatever it's about doing everything
well you know and and I think that is a
fundamental difference so when I think
about for example what's happening in
Washington DC right now where you know
very courageous mayor assumed
responsibility for the school system and
appointed Michelle Rhee who's a Teach
for America alum to run the school
system you know the majority of her
senior team or teach for america alums a
growing percentage of the school
principals ten percent in growing
including the principles of the fastest
improving and highest performing schools
or teach for america lumps and what
unites that crew is those two things
like they they are working with a level
of conviction and a level of
relentlessness that is hard to find and
at the same time you know they've put
all the all the basics at the at the
center of their agenda so knowing that
it's not any one curriculum or it's not
anyone like there's no magic solution
out there they've said you know what
most fundamentally this is about people
so we need to do everything we can to
ensure that we have the most talented
teachers the most talented principles
the most talented School District
officials they've put that at the center
of their agenda they believe that those
folks need to hold themselves
accountable for results and continuously
improve over time I mean it sounds
mundane but that is the name of the game
you know and and so I guess what what
inspires me to your question around
scale is realizing that every person in
that picture and all of the Teach for
America alums in various other
communities where there's where they're
at the center of real momentum around
reform really came into Teach for
America in the 90s our first decade when
in the whole decade we produce 3,500
Teach for America alums so the fact that
we're at the point now where you know
well over we'll bring in 4,000 core
members this year alone and I just think
gosh you know what will we be talking
about five and ten years from now i
really believe we're going to reach a
point where we have a critical mass of
leaders working from within education
and also really importantly from outside
of education as well because as much as
we'll never solve the problem without
long-term committed sustained leadership
from within we'll never solve the
problem if we don't have a policy
context and a kind of i mean think about
the influence of our journalists and of
our business leaders if we don't have
folks and influence in other sectors who
also share a deep understanding of the
problem and of the solutions
you